So welcome back to human emotion.
This is our very final closing lecture for this course.
Psychology one 31 and introduction to human emotion.
As we've taken a journey in this course through emotion,
we've been able to connect to it intimately with our own experiences of emotion
and everyday life and at the same time appreciate just how complex and how
mysterious emotion truly is by probing emotion from multiple angles and levels,
different theoretical perspectives and using different tools that scientists try
to take to quantify exactly what emotion is.
What I'd like to do in our final lecture is to recap exactly where we've been in
our journey through the world of human emotion and where do we go next in this
exciting but very young interdisciplinary field.
So in our final lecture we all ask ourselves,
is this really the end of emotion?
In many ways I think of this course as a platform for the beginning of many
years to come.
I hope for you in your own exploration of emotion and for the field of an effect
of science.
More generally.
What we'll be doing today is starting with the summary of where we've gone
through this course,
taking a time travel journey through all the different lectures and diff topics
that have spanned the realm of human emotion.
Then we'll move on to some puzzles of where do we go as a field,
what are some of the most pressing and unanswered questions to date,
and then we'll conclude with an expert interview from someone who is at the
forefront of trying to understand exactly how we take the science of emotion and
move it forward into an increasingly digital age of human interaction and
communication.
So I'll start first with where have we been in this course?
So we started this course off by first acknowledging that human emotion is
something that can be studied from a wide variety of perspectives and techniques
ranging across a wide variety of fields.
As you can see here.
And in answering some of the three main course objectives,
we've tried to first expose ourselves to all the current and contemporary
theories of emotion style science today here at the forefront of the field.
We've also really gone through systematically what are all the different methods
and tools and ways of thinking about emotions as researchers.
And finally,
and what I hope you've gained from this course is an increasing curiosity and
excitement in this new discipline charged even more than you were when you first
enrolled in this course.
To better understand exactly what is this thing we call human emotion and why it
is so important and vital for our survival as a species.
Importantly,
when we think about the course we've covered roughly as amazing as you can see
here,
20 broad topics and what I want to do is think about as we sort of spanned
through all these topics that we've covered in a relatively brief time,
what are some of the most important insights and questions we've gained?
So I'll start first here with our very first lecture.
So this is when we went through an introduction and overview of what the course
was about.
And really what we did is start with perhaps the most age old and puzzling
question of what exactly is an emotion.
We cover different historical perspectives on this issue.
Starting with the ancient Greek scholars and then moving through time to some of
the most contemporary scientists today.
Still grappling with what exactly is an emotion and how do we classify it?
Do we think of it as a discrete entity or something that we can capture more
along a dimensional approach?
Yeah.
Then we moved on to really trying to,
once we answer the question of what an emotion is,
trying to map out systematically the tools that are used both to elicit
emotions.
So trigger these feelings in people as well as then once they're triggered,
try to measure Phi them,
uh,
or measure them in a more quantified,
rigorous fashion.
So here we looked at measuring and eliciting emotions and the question that we
really tried to tackle is how exactly do we measure emotion?
So we all can relate to what an emotion is.
We've all experienced in emotion and we can all see emotions and detect them and
people around us.
But how do we try to capture it in the lab and try to quantify it from a more
scientific perspective?
Here.
We went through eight broad domains of tools that are used to trigger emotions
by current scientists in the field.
These range from using films to photos to relived emotional memories to dyadic
interactions using music,
singing as some of the most powerful tools that make us feel intense,
intense feelings,
acoustic startle reflex,
startle,
idling modulation,
and even how the directed facial action task simply by moving our face and the
muscles in it,
we can actually make ourselves feel emotions ranging from happiness to even
sadness or disgust.
Okay.
Importantly,
once we talked about how we can use these different tools to trigger an emotion,
we then went through a multi-method approach to emotion that suggests that in
order to quantify emotion response,
you need to really pay attention to it's unique and elegant components looking
across subjective behavioral and physiological response to me,
and as you saw here,
both at the level of the brain or the central nervous system,
as well as looking in the autonomic nervous system at peripheral signals like
your heart rate changing or your skin temperature increasing.
Okay?
Then we took a brief detour away from perhaps the topic of human emotion to
pause for a moment and reflect on the way in which emotions are manifested in
the broader animal kingdom.
And here we were trying to really get at the question,
do different animals like rats,
monkeys,
dogs,
do they have feelings?
So although of course in human emotion we found that we can learn a lot about
our own feelings,
but actually studying how unique versus how similar they are with other species
species near us.
And here what we did is looked at the presence or absence of what we think of as
humanlike emotions,
fear,
happiness,
anger and animals.
To help us tackle the question of to what extent are these emotions truly human,
unique or what kind of human uniqueness do emotions have?
Really,
we looked at this using a wide variety of tools that researchers use,
including both,
you know,
lab and field studies.
As you can see here by my colleague Laurie Santos.
Um,
we also realize that perhaps some of our own emotions may not be so uniquely
human,
but that we can actually see physiological similarity in some of our closest
nonhuman primates across a wide range of emotions.
As you can see here,
ranging from surprise to even anger.
And it suggests that we even share an intricate social bond and a way of
connecting emotionally through what's called impact empathy or empathic accuracy
with some of our closest canine friends who seem to have the special ability to
pick up on our own emotions and respond to them.
We then tried to explore this question of the origins of emotions or another
words where exactly did our emotions come from or evolve from in the first
place?
Our emotions evolutionarily evolved.
So here we discuss the extent to which emotions indeed are more evolutionarily
evolved versus more socially or culturally constructed.
And we began by really covering ground with what's thought to be,
you know,
the forefather of this perspective of an evolutionary approach to emotion.
Darwin who had these prescient observations in his writings,
the expression of the emotion in man and animals where he really,
you know,
had these fascinating insights into observing similar expressions of emotion
among,
you know,
human and other animals,
including dogs and cats,
and helped us trace our insights into the early emergence of emotions,
not only in humans but across species on this planet more broadly.
Then we tried to probe individual differences in emotion here.
So we looked at important sources of cultural variation,
potential gender differences between men and women,
and even the role of sexual arousal in our emotional lives.
So for example,
we were really trying to answer this question of do culture,
age,
gender,
sex,
do these change our emotional being?
Do they change who we are and what kinds of emotions we experience?
And those that we expressed to other people.
So you might remember this example from one of our earlier lectures where we
tried to look at cultural sources of variation,
emotion and found that it can even shape the way that we,
you know,
interpret and ascribe emotions to simple pictures like this of cartoon fish with
Americans.
Thinking that the fish and the front is angry and those from a more Chinese
background ascribing sadness to the fish in the front.
So we find that,
you know,
cultural profoundly shapes the way that we perceive emotions in the world around
us.
We asked the question on whether or not men and women are really that different
emotionally,
right?
And whether it was possible that they really are from,
you know,
different emotional planets.
And then we asked ourselves,
what does sex habit,
you know,
anything to do with emotion,
right?
His desire and emotion.
And how do men and women differ in their sources of sexual arousal?
And what does this tell us about the kinds of bonds they form with others and
the kinds of emotions that they experience during,
you know,
context of sexual arousal or desire.
We then moved on to look at really how do we emit or reveal our emotions to
others through our behaviors,
through our expressions.
Um,
one of my favorite topics that we covered here was the topic of laughter.
So we all laugh countless times in a given day.
And here we looked at what are the different kinds of laughs that people emit.
We talked about this concept of a laughter dictionary that's been developed to
quantify laughs at differ from what are called hisses to grunts to even cackles
and showing that these different kinds of laughters are actually perceived
differently by others.
Some kinds of laughs actually make us look more affiliative to others.
Men and women differ in the way that they laugh.
And we actually looked at different ways that laughter is actually something
that can be quite healthy for us,
even at a physical health level.
So it suggests perhaps that laughter not only helps us navigate our social
world,
but really can be a remedy to many of our physical ailments.
And then on the flip side,
we talked about crying.
So most of you probably came into this course thinking that crying serves as
Cathartic function,
right?
It helps us event our emotions,
but it seems that crying is not good for everyone.
Right?
And that it really varies depending on the context you're crying in your own
emotional background and personality style and perhaps even your gender.
So sometimes crying can help us,
but other times it may actually hurt us.
And here,
if you remember this diagram,
we saw how even brief touches to the forearm beneath the curtain between two
complete strangers,
even in the course of a few seconds,
can convey,
convey a spectrum of wildly distinct emotions ranging from love and anger to
sadness,
so that we're able simply to use this powerful modality of touch to let other
people know exactly how we're feeling.
So expression is really powerful in how we convey emotions to other people and
how we signal to ourselves the kinds of emotional states we want to feel and how
we want to regulate them.
We then moved onto more physiological approaches to motion.
Looking at to an extent,
what can we learn about our emotions through our bodily sensations?
In other words,
is our heart really a window into our feelings?
And research suggests will,
yes,
it is that as our emotions change,
so does our heart rate.
And here we explore different tools and techniques that researchers in the field
of psychophysiology use to measure the body's response and how we've been
mapping a profile of what's called emotion specificity within the autonomic
nervous system to really try to get at emotions that range from happiness to
sadness,
to fear and just how we measure these responses using a wide variety of tools.
Um,
and sort of technically how you in the lab apply these tools and quantify the
response.
Then we got up into the brain and asked ourselves,
is the brain something that was once thought solely to be devoted to rational
thinking?
Also emotional,
right?
Are there certain parts of our brain or ways that the brain connects to an
interacts with other neural systems that actually may give rise to our everyday
emotions?
We looked at tools like Fmr,
try and Eeg to study emotion in the brain as well as what are thought to be some
of the major emotional divisions in the brain,
like the limbic system,
the striatum and the neocortex.
Um,
as well as interconnectivity between these regions.
And this is one of the most cutting edge cross disciplinary approaches to
emotion today in a field referred to now as an affect of neuroscience.
We then moved on to the world of self conscious emotions and other words,
emotions that are really about the self.
So these are emotions that emerge later in life and require higher kind of
cognitive resources.
They're more complex,
they require an awareness of the self and how the self situates within a broader
social world.
Um,
and here we looked at emotions ranging from pride to also our guests.
You know,
appearance here by John.
Let's,
I'm a television writer for both 30 rock and Saturday night live undergoing one
of our standardized embarrassment eliciting pass in the laboratory,
which involves singing along to the Beatle song,
twist and shout.
So we learned not only every day,
you know,
folk but also even celebrities experience self conscious emotions like
embarrassment.
Um,
now when we think about emotions,
we've,
we know that they don't occur in a vacuum.
Rarely do we experience emotions by ourselves in our own room.
Mostly we experienced them around other people and they're often about other
people.
So we know that emotions are inherently social,
but yet to what extent do we know how emotions help us navigate in a social
world.
So here,
this was our 10th lecture.
We really tried to probe this question of to what extent can we think of
emotions in a social world?
How do they look in live interactions between people,
partners,
groups,
how do they help foster our most important social relationships with friends and
romantic partners?
And these are some of the questions that we probed in this module.
And then had special guests,
lecturers as well,
looking at topics like emotions and social interaction from Dr. David Desteno as
well as the relational context and how it shapes our emotional lives by Dr.
Margaret Clark.
Yeah.
Now when we moved through our halfway point in the course,
we segwayed into looking at this question of morality.
So here we really tried to ask the question of what role does emotion play in
making us moral creatures and how can it influence our behavior for the good and
for the bad.
So we saw definitions of morality by figures like John Height who suggests that
morals are an inherent part of what makes us human and underlie our human
goodness or our sense of virtuous behavior,
but we also saw that emotions can lead us to perform perhaps some of the most
nefarious evil acts known to mankind.
And so here we had a special guest lecture by Dr Joshua Buckholtz who help us
also understand the dark side of emotion and morality,
looking at emotion among people who are diagnosed with what's called
psychopathy.
Okay.
When we moved on to cognition here we are trying to look at the role of how
emotion shapes the way we think.
How does that shape our emotional memories?
How does it shape attention to the visual world around us,
literally causing us to change how we see the world and might even influence our
unconscious cognitive processes and emotional life?
Tracing back to early observations by Freud who suggested that the unconscious
life is a really important part of our emotional health and how recent work by
John Barge colleagues has confirmed this early intuition.
We also had a special guest lecture by Dr Marc Brackett on emotional
intelligence.
So this idea that we may vary an extent to which we perceive emotions accurately
and regulate our emotions.
Okay.
When we thought about judgment and decision making,
what we were really trying to get at is how do emotion shape some of the most
important decisions we make in everyday life.
And one place that we started looking at is how we make choices about how to
spend money,
right?
So in other words,
does our wallet reflect our feelings?
Do emotion shape how much we spend,
what we buy?
And Ken money actually by happiness.
And we found that,
well it might,
but it depends on how you spend it and perhaps you ought to be spending it on
other people instead of your house instead of yourself.
So here,
after looking at,
you know,
morality,
cognition,
decision making,
we moved on to how we actually can,
you know,
shift and modify our emotions.
So precisely how and when are we able to take the reigns over our emotions and
shape them to be the kinds of emotional experiences we want.
So we borrowed from,
you know,
some of the most commonly used and wide reaching accounts of emotion by James
Gross and colleagues when they tried to define emotion regulation as the process
by which individuals influence which emotions they have,
when they have them in how they experience and express their emotions.
And one of my fabulous graduate students gave a really interesting guest lecture
thinking about how emotion regulation shapes our social relationships and how we
can actually leverage our relationships with other people to help us change our
emotional experiences.
Okay.
Emotional development.
It's interesting we got into this later on in the course because what this is
really asking is after talking about all these different facets of emotion,
we then got to try to look at how early in our life do emotions actually begin.
So can you see emotions like happiness and sadness,
fear even in some of our youngest human infants who come to the lab.
And so here we also then when we thought about infants,
we then thought about how to emotions emerge and change the lifespan.
So here we then moved on to adolescence,
which is described as a period of all gas and no emotional breaks,
right?
So it seems that adolescents seem to constantly be on the go and have trouble
stopping or inhibiting their emotions.
So this has been coined as a period of emotional storm and stress.
What happens after adolescence?
What happens as we age into our middle and older adulthood?
Well,
what we found is a very comforting notion that near the end of our lives we
actually seem to become not only wiser but also happier based on the well
established work.
I've Dr Laura,
Laura Carstensen and colleagues,
um,
under what they call their socioemotional selectivity theory.
So as we age,
we actually become happier and we're better able to harness and control our
feelings.
Now if we look at the intersection between how emotion effects health,
we explored three broad domains,
critical to healthy survival.
This included looking at the relationship between emotion and sleep,
finding that sleep indeed seems to be a form of overnight therapy for our
emotional brain,
helping restore and sort of put back in balance our emotional wellbeing.
We also looked at the impact of stress,
both short term and long or more chronic stress on our emotional health.
Finding not surprisingly chronic stress to be detrimental to our emotional
health,
perhaps short and intermittent bouts of stress actually help us accomplish our
most important life goals and tasks.
Yeah.
Then we also looked at the role of hormones,
right?
Delving into the neuroendocrine system,
and this is a really up and coming area in the field of Africa,
science and trying to understand by measuring hormonal levels,
can we understand something about our emotions and exactly what insights can we
see and would this differ for men versus women?
And then we got to the topic that is,
uh,
something,
most personal interest to me as a clinical psychologist looking at the role of
emotional disorders.
In other words here we asked the question,
can emotion go awry?
And what we did is covered three broad themes describing the ways in which
emotion can become dysregulated,
either through extremes,
absences or disjunctions,
and how they become dysregulated and impairing in this way.
And we looked at this trans diagnostically.
So across a ride variety of clinical disorders ranging from anxiety to
depression,
mania,
schizophrenia,
and even personality disorders like borderline personality disorder.
Okay.
And then we turn to try to think about how can we use emotion to promote
increased mental health?
How can we enhance human wellbeing?
Well,
there's the topic of resilience that suggests that most people have this amazing
ability to seemingly bounce back.
You know,
like this beach ball you see here,
we're all like these emotional beach balls in many ways that we can bounce back
even from some of the most difficult life traumas.
And here we also had a fantastic guest lecture from a renowned expert on emotion
in psychotherapy telling us how we can sort of translate these insights from a
course like this on human emotion to develop more targeted interventions to help
people both increase positive emotion and decreased distressing and impairing
negative emotions.
Okay?
And we concluded by turning to a topic of fascination to human beings for
centuries,
which is happiness.
And we started by asking exactly what is happiness,
how do people define it and how can we find it in a society with an ever
increasing desire to become happy.
Yeah.
Importantly,
we also talked about some caveats and this is the work that I specialize in in
my laboratory here at Yale,
which is looking at the other side of happiness,
realizing that happiness,
like any state in life has two sides.
There's a good side and adaptive side,
but there may also be a dark side of happiness.
Talking about the ways in which happiness is experienced too intensely in the
wrong context or pursued for the wrong reasons,
it may actually backfire and decrease our overall sense of wellbeing.
Um,
and this is something that if you're interested in learning more about,
you can check out my lab,
the positive emotion and psych pathology lab.
Um,
www.yalepeplab.com.
Okay.
And this is something that we've been pursuing,
um,
with another scholar in the field.
Judith Moskowitz,
I'm with a book we have coming out called seeing both sides,
the light and dark side of positive emotions.
So here we try to take a comprehensive approach to happiness and wellbeing by
looking at not only the ways that,
that these states are good for us,
but when and how they can actually be too much and be too our emotional
disadvantage.
So it's coming soon.
So stay tuned.
We also had a very special guest lecturer from philosopher and cognitive
scientists,
Josh know who helped us think about how our morality,
our sense of goodness and badness,
how that can shape the way we perceive happiness and others and how we ascribe
happiness to other people as well.
And now here we are,
you know,
summarizing this course and looking ahead to the future.
And I hope that when we think about summarizing this course,
it's important to really think about the unique aspects and experiences at this
course provided,
which really I would think are like any other course on human emotion you've
seen before.
So in addition to covering some of these exciting topics,
you've been able to really view these fantastic videotape guests lectures that
had been broken up into 20 minute modules.
So you've had three 20 minute modules for each lecture with takeaway questions
to help hone some of the most critical insights and points covered in each
lecture.
You've also had the opportunity to engage in interactive discussions using state
of the art online technology to have discussions about some of these topics,
some of the controversies behind them with both myself as the professor,
as well as some of my graduate student teaching fellows.
And finally,
perhaps one of the most treasured unique components of this course is for the
first time ever and this expert and emotion interview series that aired
specially for this course.
So this included a state of art series that conducted interviews with experts in
emotion across the entire country.
And here you had the opportunity to view live conversations with visionary
figures in the field,
including those names listed here who directly mapped onto the exciting research
that we talked about in lecture and that you covered in your readings.
So this is something that I think unlike any other course,
you were not only able to read about some of these insights in the field of
human ocean,
but actually be able to literally hear and see the minds behind them.
So we covered where we went.
Now where do we go from here?
So we know that emotion is this exciting and interdisciplinary field and it's
also one that's relatively new.
So we've seen recent interest and an explosion of scientific attention only in
the past few decades.
So in many ways this leaves more unanswered questions than answered questions
and many opportunities for people and students like you to become engaged in
this field and move it forward into whole new territories.
So what I'll try to do is conclude by highlighting what I think of the,
some of the perhaps key puzzles.
I'll talk about four of them and,
but I want to emphasize that these are just four puzzles and there are likely
countless more puzzles out there as we move forward into brave new world of
human emotion.
So when we think about some of the puzzles,
one of the ones that has come up consistently is trying to link the kinds of
emotional experiences that we see in the lab to the real world.
Emotions then unfold around us every day in our own lives.
So here what I think is a critical input,
important direction to move forward,
and it's to try to translate what we measure in the lab to what we see out there
in the world in front of us,
and really try to capture the essence of what we all are so familiar with.
And it's so intimate to all of us as the experience of feeling emotion.
I think one of the other important puzzle pieces here is to use a multi-method
approach.
So we've talked about emotion as something that has multiple components,
right?
It has a subjective response,
a behavioral display,
physiological features,
and the autonomic nervous system in the brain,
and also up and coming insights and genetics.
And more and more as we move forward,
as we measure emotion,
it's critical that we integrate these tools and that we try to engage in ever
increasing interdisciplinary collaborations.
Not only between among psychologists with different areas of specialization,
but also with neuroscientists,
geneticists,
sociologists,
anthropologists,
to really gain the most comprehensive portrait of emotion that we can.
And I think for many of us,
a lot of early work on emotion,
especially in clinical psychology,
often focused on identifying patterns of distress and how we can alleviate
people suffering.
So how can we make people feel less anxious or less depressed?
But there's been an ever increasing movement now to think about how can we use
emotion to better understand and cultivate a good life?
So one that is full,
not only of happiness,
but of meaning and promoting compassion.
So this is a really important emerging trend in the field to think about not
only the ways in which emotions can lead us to suffer,
but how we can leverage our emotions and understand them to build the best
possible life for us as human beings.
And finally,
emotion and technology.
So we're existing in an ever increasing technological world.
And how can we use some of these,
you know,
commonly used social media tools,
platforms,
things like Facebook and Twitter.
Um,
how do we understand the way in which emotion unfolds in these contexts and how
does it change who we are?
How does it change the kinds of emotions we expressed to other people?
So with this topic,
it actually helps us segway into our very final expert interview with the,
a renowned expert on this topic and who works at Facebook as the engineering
director.
So here are experts in emotion interview will be with Arturo Bihar,
the director of engineering at Facebook,
and he'll be speaking with us on emotion and social media.
Arturo as director of engineering at Facebook,
has worked on social tools to help people be more mindful of each other.
This includes such areas as identity,
harm and abuse prevention,
ways to develop better online citizens and tools designed to help resolve
conflicts between individuals such as bullying.
Previously he worked at Yahoo where he worked with a global team dedicated to
providing a secure online experience.
So I now turn to our last experts and emotion interview together with our Touro
Bihar on emotion and social media.
Thank you for a wonderful course and farewell.